θα το συζητήσουμε αλλά σήμερα δεν συζητήθηκε ούτε στο φιλικό επίπεδο ούτε στίλνα σεμέσε σίσ
κάποιος άλλος σας ιεπιδήο σας έρχεταρκετέραναιπο είναι δίπλαμας είναι δίπλα στυνομόσπο νεδια οι οικογένεια βεέείναι
διδήπλα στην στην στην ομωσπονιία και τουτοοπολέόμως δαδι αδελφή του εμαικέλα είναι από τους θενούς
μου συναι εργάτες οιδιαίτερα σε θέματα που έχουν να κάνουν με το γίναικίο μικαέλεκτός που
είναι τσιμάνα και τις εθνικής γυναικό έχει μας εκπροσωπί και στην στη φύπαγορο στην επιτροπή
γίναίκα και γαλοθόσφερα τις φύπα γροαλλά αλά είναι κοντά στην οσπονηδασε φιλικών επίπεδο ναι έχουμδεν
θα μπορώ να πω δεν θα το ψέμανεάρά ένασμές έφυγε σας ανδιάφερε δεν είναι σέσμέσα
όσαχ είναι σχεδόν όπότε μπορεί σεέ του είναι στην κύπρο το καλοκαίρι πήγαμε μαζί σεσε
ακατημίες παρουσιάστηκε μίλησε στα παιδίά για διάφορα θέατα είναι δίπλα μας εναι να πολύ σύμθε
τον ζήτημα είναι περίπλοκον είναι δύσκολο τοψαξες όμως ότι μπορούμε από το φλευάρι να δεν
περάσει γθα το πω κάπως πιο γεννικά η κανονισμί σου δίνουν το δικίεωμα ύποπροεποθέσεις να
γίνει μεταγραφί πέκτι που αγωνίστηκε σε μια είναιθνίκη σε μια αάλληνεθνική εαν καιφόσον πληρούν τα
κριτήρια τα οποία τήθονται στον κανονισμό καταφήνουμε μέχριαδώ μάλισα ωράτ ώρα ητα έχουμε στυμφωνήσει με
τορά έχει το διαδατεα όχι δεν το έχει όμως ποντία μπορεκηενεκδηρκτομε πρκή δημοκρατία διότι ασαμε
και αυτόν ότι πήρεν το διεβατήρι όχι με τοράι υπάρχειμια προσυμφωνία